[Music]
there's sex Island news I submitted by
Moses from London Oh
London's kind of ironic that his name's
Moses and he's submitting about set oh
because it's a biblical thing yeah I'm
pretty sure Moses [ __ ] there was sex in
the Bible yeah he split that [ __ ] red
puss we all know that that can happen
without having sex Virgin Mary I am made
to staff down an island resort is
offering guest drugs alcohol and
unlimited sex with prostitutes that
sounds great that is [ __ ] disgusting
where is this yeah where so I could shut
it down and do it it sounds like a dream
come true for other people yeah for
other people go so this company called
good girls sounds cheap though yeah I
don't like the name of it but I want to
hear my other side and they uploaded
this video promoting this crazy weekend
in November with all these prostitutes
are they saying that they're gonna have
60 prostitutes only exerting guests are
allowed to go oh wow there's more women
than men mm-hmm and they're saying that
you can pick like two to be with you at
all times and then you can switch with
other girls whenever you want
oh my Pokemon Trading Cards it's a
private island that they're not telling
you exactly where it is but it seems
like it's in the Caribbean that's so sad
yeah Mon it's like prostitutes are like
really hot but then when I see them and
then I I'm like around them I'm like you
just you're so greedy you want my money
you want their bodies I think cuz I get
turned on by genuinely being like so
when I go to the strip club unwillingly
and my friends just drag me there I'm
there I'm your friend
friends I'm just like these girls just
want my money they don't like me like
they're lying like they come up to me
you wanna dance you don't wanna dance
you want my money and I get my feeling
sir because all I I'm like that's my
money I work hard for like like rubbings
should be free so would you prefer
they're like you're cute but I really
just want your money then you'd be like
the a.m. town no cuz there's no
emotional connection I'm like I'm like
you're greedy but you're horny what do
you care I care because what turns me on
is when someone likes you
that's what people should open they
should open up emotional sex or strip
strip clubs it's called marriage bro no
no that's disabled that's called being
fresh dirty [ __ ] I mean French dirty
[ __ ] brush because it's brand-new but
dirty cuz it's a [ __ ] so not super Sun
horse I think it'll be cool though like
they come in but they're not strippers
at first they they talk to you they chat
you up and they go you know what I think
we didn't take this to the next level
and the pole comes down you know this
trip that will take place between
November 24th and 27th and it's $5,000
well it's for Thanksgiving is that
during yeah well festive they had two
promotional videos I'm just gonna show
you one and the one that looks what do
they leave out here here we go white on
it the GoPro three I know what the hell
that's the worst video are they making
Oh xxx girl honest too small limited sex
and clothes they should say it's not
free right it's a cool song I want to go
on the island you know how I would feel
so if I was single like I will go on
there right cuz like my dirty friends
would force me to play with the boob and
I'll be thinking what kind of life is
yeah what are your thumbs doing so I
will be playing
yeah so I'll be playing with the boob
right and then I'll just be thinking
like what kind of parents did you have
like what kind of poor situation were
you yeah well I'm like your breasts are
amazing but what kind of tragedy did you
have to go through to go you have to
[ __ ] sell yourself woman
you know honestly all right yeah I think
that would feel bad like I'll be there
the whole time and all my friends will
be like yeah so such a tragic path but
in my mind I'm thinking who deserve
better you probably came from a broken
home and I'm I'm dying inside I'm sad
then I can't I can't really relax
because it's fake it's not like you made
it you're this superstar rock musician
and you're on a boat full of people who
actually like your talent and they're
just there because they want to be with
this magical king that's a lot different
that still sounds fake if anybody out
there is a legit stripper how much do
you make not Matt Matt Matt you little
[ __ ] 14 year olds that are pretending
to be somebody else like an actual
stripper how much do you think how much
do you make on a night on a good night
it depends on location on a hot day
and what time of day or night because I
wonder cuz like if they're stripping and
they're making I don't know let's say in
tips like two grand a month
that's pretty [ __ ] good sometimes you
can make a grand a night yeah two grand
a month
dude there's girls that make like six
figures really like dr. money oh yeah
cuz you don't want to get pummeled by
[ __ ] stranger dick all the time no
put your humble stupid you're
controlling the pummeling you mean she's
like come on oh I know the first day
there will be a sex session on the
private island where any of the
participants can join and then on the
second like morning yoga class everyone
shows up with [ __ ] pointy dicks they
just start [ __ ] apparently are their
qualifications to be a part of this
probably is not really [ __ ] well the
girls yeah but I don't know about the
actual customer it doesn't seem like it
cuz on the website they're just saying
like seven tickets left and then you're
just putting your whole info like your
credit how much mrs. Coste five thousand
what's a bit but that's not including
airfare that's still not bad how many
days three B yeah three 24:27 because
it's like a ninety nine percent died
dream come true so if you're 5 G's to
pay for that's pretty good yeah I don't
know if I start the day with with sex
and I already came I'll be like yeah I'm
gonna go fishing people [ __ ] in the
background Joe just there is gossip on
the boat I was like I got my come out
already I'm not trying to [ __ ] anymore
[Music]
cuz you know like after you know you're
you're just like Mother Teresa
you're the most unworn uist person on on
earth well I mean like now I'm not in
high school anymore you know I can't go
over and over I just go [ __ ] catch a
dolphin they try to seduce you man I
need a good lunch break and then I'll
probably go back to it that's all bad
[ __ ] right there I did that we
already [ __ ] give me a sandwich I know
I came already you guys are not even
sexual features to me anymore
the second day they're saying that there
will be each client will have half an
hour with 16 girls at once so you just
have your own orgy and then on the third
and fourth days it will be parties on
luxury yacht third and fourth days at
they're only three days apparently
there's third and fourth I don't know
bonus days we it will be DJ and drugs
and all that [ __ ] but they are saying
that prostitution is not illegal in
Columbia but pimping is a crime so don't
get tempted a pimp when you see a
prostitute know that company could be
like in trouble because they're just
providing like what makes you a pimp
when you slap them or is it like we have
a cheetah print suit
collect money that they're making it
because the company's paying the
prostitutes and then they're collecting
the money so that is pimping well that's
pimping though Wow employing you're the
boss and you're paying your employees
because it's specifically sex yeah I
mean that's that's what pimps do they
arrange the sex Oh what did you think of
paint boys I don't know I never really
thought about it unless it was a
Halloween costume hires them as servers
and they pay them as servers like we
need waitresses for this boat yeah but
they're just a sex on their own yeah
what I thought pimps did actually was
just bodyguards no so what pimps do is
they find customers for the hooker my
bed yeah come up watch this new show
that just came out I know what you're
talking about that one they actually got
HBO right yeah that one girls Franco
yeah and then the other girl what's her
name the one that has a famous brother
she's like everywhere I forgot I'm
blinking underneath y'all talking about
nas Oh Jake Gyllenhaal yeah his brother
Bailey P yes you guys know what the [ __ ]
they're just having their own
conversation and the audience is
watching [ __ ] JK news right now right
jakey party kiss it's good in the
[ __ ] TIFF blanks all right I actually
forgot we're shooting right now no show
with
sir JK party if you guys like watching
these type of games go to JK party
subscribe at either you're talking about
series oh yeah yeah yeah so then right
there she was explaining that she didn't
want to pimp because she could take care
of herself
yeah that's what the whole point of me
bringing that and that's why I thought
that's what pimps do they're just
bodyguards but I didn't know they
facilitated there with the middlemen now
I know thank you guys how's 12 a.m. in
the morning let's go get them a Sikh oh
oh
coyote tweto videos talking about food
that have nothing to do with article at
the bt mother day oh [ __ ] my mother too
it's nothing peachy Padre that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] bad as [ __ ] huh no [ __ ] is just
a general term
I can't yeah he earned it okay yeah
baddest you tell me right now if we were
going out clubbing right and I was like
[ __ ] you look bad as [ __ ] if you're gay
that's okay well I mean you are David
come on [ __ ] you look good but that's
crazy how you did exactly but we're not
friends and we didn't have any
interaction did you see all that sass
though you went [ __ ] you look I know
but this is dead it's me look good
that's what's it anyway yeah I know I'll
add a little [ __ ] hay to it that's
fine then they step with a tag what
could carry hey guys I hope you enjoyed
that episode of just kidding news and if
you did really enjoyed or if you have
thoughts about what you just watched
leave a comment down below and let us
know and for the next video click right
up here
[Music]